hey it's becca and this is temperance
part two um and in this video i'll be
talking more about how exactly over the
course of the 1830s until
mostly the 1860s
the temperance movement took root in
america and how it became this national
phenomenon so a lot of it had to do with
temperance society so in the last video
i mentioned that the american temperance
society was founded in 1826 so that's
but the american temperance society
really was this group of upper-class
northern
white dudes
saying oh well we should probably make
sure that people don't drink as much but
this idea didn't take off until the rise
of tetotalism so tetotalism is very
different than temperance tetotalism
and so tetotalism is the idea that
people should not temper their alcohol
consumption that they should drink no
alcohol so the origin of this word is
debated among historians and there's
kind of two funny stories one is the
idea that when you would sign a pledge
so let's say i was going to pledge that
i would drink no alcohol and join the
american temperance society right here i
would have to sign my name like that
and write my name becca
or the other idea is that there was this
temperance activist and he was trying to
convince people to stop drinking alcohol
and he said you don't have to stop
drinking hard alcohol you have to to to
totally abstain and that's where tea
totalism came from his stutter just kind
of a fun little factoid about tetotalism
but this idea of signing a pledge to
drink no alcohol was really popular
among these different societies that
started popping up so the american
temperance society was not quite as
effective
but the washingtonian tempered society
started in the 1840s in 1840 actually
the washingtonian temperance society
and the washingtonian tempered society
was different than the american
temperance society because it kind of
looked a little bit more like
the 19th century version of alcoholics
anonymous people would come together and
talk about their problems there wasn't
really a treatment aspect it wasn't
super effective in stopping people from
drinking alcohol because a pledge people
realized wasn't actually going to stop
alcoholics from drinking however the
washingtonian tempered society was more
this group of middle-class men and they
would all come together and try and curb
their consumption so during this time
there were also lots of prohibitory laws
being passed by the states so
different states at different times
during the early 1800s started to try
and curb consumption by enacting laws
they realized that the pledges you know
me signing my name like this didn't
actually help that much and so they
needed to do something legally the first
temperance law was passed by maine in
1838 maine and this law just outlawed
the sale of hard liquor but slowly
states across the country started
banning alcohol consumption altogether
so this was kind of happening all
throughout here in 12 15 states had some
sort of regulatory law on alcohol
so over this time period from the 1830s
to the 1860s
americans were not just taking pledges
like they were up here with the american
temperance society and the washingtonian
temperate society but they were actually
enacting laws
temperance went really mainstream it
wasn't just this idea that you were
going to sign a pledge to stop drinking
hard alcohol there were going to be laws
that would bind you to drink no alcohol
so on top of this legal transition there
was also a big social and media campaign
about the terrors and evils of alcohol
so right over here is the drunkard's
progress
this is a really famous lithograph
created by nathaniel courier this was in
1846 so drunkard's progress right over
here and the drunkard's progress as you
can see
shows the kind of cyclic
nature of the alcoholic first he's just
drinking at home then he's drinking with
friends
and then
oh what is going on there um he is not
going to be going to the factory today
for work so the trunk started not as a
drunk but as your average guy just
having a drink here or there then you
would see them go through each of these
steps you see step two step three step
four over here step five seems like he's
just hanging out with his buddies having
a good time but then it really slowly
deteriorated into something that
americans didn't want so then in 1853 i
guess that's kind of in here 1853
this media campaign just took off with
10 nights in a bar room so 10 nights in
a bar room
here it is 10 nights in a bar room
this is one of the pictures in the book
this really had just huge mainstream
reach almost everyone read it
and then they started putting on plays
of it depicting just how drunk people
got and how terrible that was for
everyone involved 10 nights in a bar
room had this really national reach and
it was similar to that of harriet
beecher stowe and uncle tom's cabin
in the abolition movement so this was
this rhetoric that made the temperance
movement take off so you're probably
wondering
then what what what happened to
temperance why did prohibition not
happen until 1920. and so this has a lot
to do with the abolition movement so the
abolition movement was taking off right
around here abolition
and the abolition movement was the idea
that
slavery had to be ended
right now today
abolition was the focus of the american
people come the mid-1800s and this
really put temperance on hold and so
temperance would come back um after the
civil war and after slavery was
abolished so you can learn more about
post bellum temperance post bellum that
means after the civil war
post bellum temperance and
prohibition
in the khan academy article titled
prohibition uh you can check that out
and learn a little bit more about how
this whole crazy story ended